and back to Colorado to go skiing and I
was able to figure a way to put a
layover in LA so I could stop and hang
out with Liz for the day and hopefully
surprise her at her work at BuzzFeed hey
I got an Olympian to go on a date with
me his name is Robbie
[Music]
I decided to come down here to LA
because we had such a fun time in South
Korea I thought why not keep playing
with it talking with her and see how
everything goes
so today's goal is just to have fun
enjoy each other's company and then
hopefully up the other day maybe get a
kiss
no just Robbie oh it's just oh my god
I'm just like I'm just like this is
Robbie I'm at the Olympics
more like tattling problem this is an
amazing love story and I'm just so here
for that way love you super fun to go
surfing today I wouldn't surfing once
when I was like little so I'm definitely
not gonna be as good as the pro right
here but you know we'll see our family
think over this there's something down
there justify enjoy yourself away
they're not like it Mary's saying like
like obviously have a lot of things
we're trying to do right now so it's not
as more just like right now just have
fun enjoy the moment
just Robbie and I are headed to the
beach we're like chatting in the car and
everything's going well like it he's
really easy to talk to and it's also
very smooth not as smooth as many
buttons on batteries
little person about you
Siri excited to go out with Liz on the
waves let's see how it goes he's ready
to get
they'll survive
like literally they'll go into my board
so I can only imagine how this
surfing is harder than it looks the
waves of super tan and super chill but
actually like when you're out there
exhausted super fun though I'm pumped
that liz is out here getting up on some
of the ways
it's ready dude just got done surfing
with Robbie like while we're out there
we only get a little bit of time
together but not enough by just squeeze
a kiss in so that was kind of a bummer
won't be for the next section of this
date that maybe I could find a time to
squeeze a kissing so what what's next
for you are you waiting to hear back
from places or something yeah I mean
they're like a company in Florida or a
company in Washington DC mom I mean Liz
chill out on the job stop okay like have
tons of time to like my life get a job
and grow up yeah well this was such an
amazing date and I really hope that I
get to see you again one day I'd hope so
too this is super fun then let's just
stay in contact and see where it goes
okay
I'll see you later you know I'm not
totally sure of Robbie's intentions it
seems like he just wants to have fun and
live life whereas I am you know very
focused on my career and I live in LA
and I'm not going all over the place as
much as he is and figuring out where I'm
gonna be living so you know where I took
these two very different stages of our
life and you know I really like spending
time with him I just really don't know
what's gonna happen next
[Music]